this video was made possible by
brilliant learn complex topics simply
for 20 off by being one of the first 200
to sign up
at brilliant.org wendover the
airline business model is broken
back in late 2019 kovit 19
came along borders worldwide closed
down businesses halted work travel
all but a select few individuals
cancelled their trips
in the time when all but the most
critical contact was to be avoided to
hold the virus at bay
travel was just not a risk worth taking
for most
one of the most major issues for the
airline industry though
is not that demand is lower lower demand
is bad it's wreaking havoc on the
industry but it
is a potentially surmountable problem if
an airline knew that 2020 would be 75
down 2021 55 down and 2022 30
down the solution would be simple they
downsize their schedule cut back on
routes
unload assets for low employees and just
become a smaller airline for the next
few years
these are in fact the tactics airlines
are using regardless
but they don't fully solve the overall
problem
that's because even after airlines
solved the problem of being
too big for what the travel market has
become the true issue
the one that will plague the industry
for the entirety of its period of
recovery
is that even after they downsize they
just don't know
how many people want to fly
now think back to travel in the time
before coronavirus
how full were the planes you were on how
often was that seat next to you free
the answer is almost certainly sometimes
but not
that often on average 85 percent of
airplane seats in the us
were filled in 2019 slightly higher than
the world average of 83 percent
some airlines achieved even better than
this ryanair for example
filled 96 of its seats in 2019.
now simultaneously when was the last
time
that you've gone to buy a ticket for a
flight but there were none
available this too certainly happens
but it's quite rare it might cost quite
a lot
but if you want to buy a ticket to a
flight it'll almost always be available
no matter how close to departure it is
this is very very intentional
now normally the day-to-day job of
adjusting the price of flights to
extract every potential dollar out of
them
is handled by computers specifically the
complex revenue management software on
them
around early march 2020 though the
computers
started to go haywire people weren't
booking like they were supposed to
so the computers lowered the price that
should lead to bookings picking up
but they didn't which confused the
computers even more
which lowered the price further this
went on
and on and on until the point where you
could book flights from new york to
london for example
for just one or two hundred dollars
round trip hours before departure
it'd be easy to say prices were low
because demand was
but that's not exactly the truth it's
just a byproduct
of the truth the computers and their
revenue management software
were tasked to extract the most revenue
possible
regardless of demand but in this case
they failed
now normally businesses focus more on
matching supply to demand
not demand to supply because regulating
demand
is very very difficult airlines however
do both simultaneously this is because
they just can't regulate supply to match
demand
that well demand for travel fluctuates
depending on which hour of
which day of which year it is airlines
just can't fluctuate their schedule to
match that
entirely for example airlines in the us
making their 2020 schedules
knew that last year 2 million 487
398 people traveled in the u.s on the
second thursday in april
well 2 million 616 1558 people did on
the third thursday
for the most part though airlines will
operate the same schedules
on both of those thursdays that's
because the complexity of adjusting the
schedule to such small changes
just isn't worth the money it would save
by operating slightly fuller flights
therefore rather than rapidly adjusting
supply to match demand they rapidly
adjust demand
to fit supply you can see this in action
by looking at
travel trends in the u.s the least busy
quarter in 2019 for air travel was the
first
january february and march with 210
million passengers
the most busy quarter meanwhile was the
third july
august and september with 243 million
passengers
now that's not that much of a difference
the third quarter including the height
of the summer travel season
was only 16 percent busier than the
first quarter
encompassing the depths of winter but is
it truly that demand is only 16
higher in the summer than winter or is
it that airlines are regulating demand
to increase it in the winter and
suppress it in the summer
all evidence points to the latter so
airlines have this balancing act to
perform they want to be sure that they
can capture as much of the high demand
in the summer as possible
but they also don't want to have a bunch
of planes and staff sitting around
in the lower demand winter as that costs
quite a lot
rather than flying a stable number of
flights year round or regulating demand
to keep it stable year round
they do a little of both and meet in the
middle
the supply side is the easy bit there is
a certain predictable ebb and flow to
the yearly cycle of travel
for a given market for a given type of
traveler
for example take the american business
airlines know that the week with the
lowest demand for travel from this
demographic is the last of the year
after christmas followed by the first of
the year the second to last of the year
the week of the fourth of july then the
week of thanksgiving
with this info airlines can craft a
schedule that
over those weeks emphasizes leisure
focused destinations over
business ones they might decide that in
the last week of the year
they'll fly more flights to florida and
fewer to chicago
simultaneously though airlines know that
september
october and the week before thanksgiving
are the strongest period of the year for
business travel
so they might increase the number of
flights on common business routes over
that time
so airlines tweak their schedule mostly
on a month to month or week to week
basis
but for those day-to-day or hour-to-hour
shifts in demand
they rely on regulating demand
the number one tool used to do this is
pricing
and we can see this in action currently
if you want to book a ticket to fly
united airlines from newark to eagle
county airport in colorado
on january 1st 2021 it would cost you
353 dollars
if you were to book united airlines from
newark airport to denver international
airport on january 1st though
it would cost you 134
so flying to eagle county is two and a
half times more expensive than flying to
denver
even though it is only 120 miles further
from new york
to united the cost of operating these
two flights are nearly
identical it's the same aircraft type
and roughly the same flight length
there might be slight economies of scale
by flying to denver as it's a baker
airport
and there's a greater potential of a
flight diversion at eagle county airport
sentence in the mountains
but overall the costs are very similar
what accounts for the difference in
price is demand
not cost united airlines thinks it knows
that
four months prior to the flight it can
charge 353 dollars for the flight to
eagle county
and still end up with a full plane
meanwhile
to end up with a full plane to denver it
has to price it at 134
these prices will increase as it gets
closer to departure but just because of
the way people book their travel to
eagle county airport
353 dollars is the right price
right now so how does united know this
well because it's what it did last year
and it worked
airlines greatest asset truly is their
data
united airlines knows exactly how much
they need to price their flights at a
certain level of fullness and a certain
number of days before departure
and that means they can eke out every
single bit of potential revenue
from a given flight if united priced the
eagle county flight too high
they might end up with empty seats which
is terrible for an airline
every time a plane takes off with an
empty seat the airline is losing out on
potential revenue
aside from taxes airport fees and
catering costs
there's essentially no extra cost to
carrying an additional passenger
so selling a cheap ticket over no ticket
is always worth it
simultaneously though if an airline
prices a flight too low
they might sell out of seats too early
losing out on the potential to sell
high-priced tickets to last-minute
travelers who generally are those
traveling for work who aren't paying for
themselves
so airlines rely on these price
fluctuations to end up with a plane
exactly full exactly a departure
therefore
in theory extracting the exact highest
potential level of revenue
from the flight this makes the problem
rather
obvious airlines simply don't know what
the recovery will look like
specifically the computers don't know
how people will respond
to changes in pricing so they don't know
how to extract the most possible revenue
from a flight by ending up with an
exactly full flight
exactly at departure the airline
industry has had sharp drop-offs in
demand before
but typically only in response to
financial crises or
terrorist attacks in this case in a
pandemic
the closest equivalent happened 100
years ago
in 1918 when the commercial aviation
industry was only in
its infancy therefore the aviation
industry as a whole
and especially individual airlines have
no data
and no idea what the demand patterns
during and after a pandemic will be like
after the initial drop off in travel and
the plummet in pricing and response
airlines essentially turned off the
computers shut down the revenue
management algorithms
they've gone back to relying on the
humans who traditionally are only there
to tweak what the computer thinks
that's because the humans were able to
realize something that the computers
could not
traditionally airline demand is quite
elastic
people will often decide whether or not
to book based on the price
it is exactly this in fact that makes it
possible
for the airlines to regulate demand by
changing prices
in the midst of the initial stay-at-home
orders though the only type of person
who would fly
was someone who needed to fly someone
who would pay whatever it cost
to get that ticket therefore there was
no sense in lowering prices
because that wouldn't stimulate demand
it would only reduce
revenue they also didn't jack them up
tremendously
cautious not to get into the public
relations nightmare of price gouging
but they more or less just kept them
stable to what a normal april would look
like
as may came about and there was a small
initial restart to discretionary travel
most every american airline lowered
prices by about 10 to 20 percent to
stimulate demand
slightly the problem though is that
there are still
way too many variables impacting travel
to accurately predict and stimulate
demand
american airlines for example took a big
gamble
in may when they were crafting their
revised summer schedule
they accurately surmised that people who
were vacationing in summer 2020
would be particularly interested in
destinations where the focus was the
outdoors
such as at the beach they also knew that
many of the traditional beach
destinations that americans travel to in
the caribbean
would be shut behind closed borders so
demand for this type of vacation
would naturally shift domestically to
florida this hypothesis was further
supported by the fact that
in may when they were working on this
schedule florida had one of the lowest
rates of infection in the u.s
therefore the airline decided to add
loads of capacity into florida to
account for the relatively high demand
it expected
of course starting in early june there
began a steep spike
in the state's covet cases leading to
increased wariness
among consumers to travel to the state
also on a more general level
much of the summer travel season in the
us did not live up to airlines
expectations
due to a second spike in nationwide case
numbers and increasing domestic travel
restrictions
passenger demand trends returned
slightly closer to the april 2020
scenario
where it was less and less the cost of
travel that stimulated demand
and rather external conditions covid has
turned the job of those
in revenue management at airlines closer
to an art
than a science with decades upon decades
of data
airlines got good at modeling the
predictable patterns of travelers but
failed to consider the possibility for
the unimaginable
now not only is overall demand lower but
airlines can't even extract the same
level of revenue from the same number of
travelers on a given flight
this unpredictability has a quite
literal monetary cost for airlines
so that means that even when the
travelers come back
even when the airports are full again
true recovery
will not happen until passengers are
predictable
again uncertainty
is not just a word it's a force of
nature that we can never get rid of
which is why mathematics has set up a
system of tools to address it
the mathematics of uncertainty is
fascinating and an incredibly powerful
analytical tool
but it's an area of math that most
people don't know a lot about
i certainly didn't until the new
brilliant course on knowledge and
uncertainty came around
this and all of brilliant's courses are
designed so they take
these big complex subjects and teach
them in an intuitive way
with visuals interactive elements and
clear explanations
all you need to do to learn about
uncertainty or computer science or math
or science
is commit to working through the course
regularly after watching this video
taking the course on uncertainty will be
even more interesting for you
as you'll be learning the exact sort of
math that those working in revenue
management at airlines
are using to try to work their way
through their massive uncertainty
problem
so commit to learning today and be one
of the first 200 to sign up at
brilliant.org
wendover so you get a 20 discount